c'è una pistolina la posso usare contro
nonno ciak che si è sbagliato
siete pronti per il gioco più
intelligente dell'anno
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono video
sono farjane ed oggi siamo su peak siamo
arrivati al capitolo 4 che è l'ultimo
round 1 ragazzi en plein facciamo questo
round 1 perfetto che sarebbe la via è
quella per andare affanculo nuclear trip
in una passeggiata al nucleare perché
c'è la torre eiffel lui siamo noi saremo
in cima la buongiorno che scritti of
hell e attore feltri cedam solo
champions league giorgio la champions
league casa devo fare mi butto giù ho
preso un pezzo di legno
vattene affanculo questo è successo lo
ha mangiato era giusto non è vero non ci
che ora il primo l'ho fatto non ci posso
che mai successo c'è una m gozzi quelle
godzilla quale le superchicche non ho
veramente parole le superchicche loro
preso questo coso andato a godzilla
deciso tieni così oddio cosa è successo
grazie non è servito a niente ragazzi
però ci ho provato perché peccato che se
ci azzeccava ho fatto tre su tre è una
mummia che dovrò darvi la bomba per
forza perché sennò non capisco meno che
non ci sia una stanza nascosta non ci
credo non è vero non è vero avrò
sbagliato cazzo sbaglia però l'ho
trovata non ci posso credere o vi giuro
che non lo sapevo cliccato a carissimo
perché c'è sempre della birra dovunque
vado maledizione vabbè verso la sulle
sue barili un per cento di alcol e lo
beve non è vero è se la ride lui
per carità di dio veramente veramente
era giusto non ci posso credere
satellite ragazzi non ho capito
va bene non importa loro oxygen ossigeno
basso cosa facciamo
apriamo il portellone
tu sei sta roba a dove momento ho capito
ho capito ho capito popolari fare lo
facciamo commentato mi sono schiantato
su meteorite neanche dire che è finito
l'ossigeno casa bianca è la
rappresentazione di obama più bella
della storia dove mpx ai là dietro la
tenda va bene
bello cia obama sono nella tenda tu non
far caso a me che non mi non mi avete
nessuno ci sono nella tenda per carità
faccio sparire la bomba o salvato la
situazione ho salvato la casa bianca
l'ossigeno lì sopra per forza così
eccolo l'ossigeno adesso è alto voglio
stringere la mano al tipo che ha fatto
sto gioco vi giuro voglio conoscerlo vi
prego le superchicche letto ho preso una
super chicca tieniti regala una super
chi va bene come che si chiamava quella
dolly non li ha mai giusto importante
che sia giusto va bene siamo all'ultima
che crei allora credo sia così bomba
apri rimpiazza hanno chiuso tutte e due
la testa va bene ma ho vinto ho vinto
vinto l'importante è convinto frotte
sega ma pixel
ce l'ho fatta un'altra volta ragazzi
sono orgoglioso di me stesso
allora questo l'ho fatto mancano questi
due e poi ho finito il gioco in teoria
credo è poi non so se c'è qualcos'altro
mai giocato a tanta merda in tutta la
mia vita
sei pronto mcrae sar let's get well face
bomber round 3 capitolo iv media
incredibile salve ragazzo è phinet
freddy's spiegando 6 sta roba da mila
torcia che mi serve ok che cazzo fa non
sa che qua dentro
salve niente scuse è un peccato perché
avevo fatto una bellissima scoperta lega
perché non saltato uno sa perché lo puoi
finire in due modi ma non ho capito
perché ha saltato uno no non ho capi o
raga non sto capendo un cazzo perché
succedono cose perché mi salta i livelli
cos'è sta roba
accede solo sono tre quindi ok quindi
questo è più difficile
minchia un casino colpisci batman con
l'estintore giusto perfetto è perfetto
non avevo dubbi
niente regali o sbagliati tutti però non
ho capito perché di santa i livelli
perché ce ne sono altri che sono sempre
uguali e mohair e spiega mi l'ho fatto
era giusto sa perché si divide in due
parti ma ma [ __ ]
ci ho messo un ora solo per far questo e
mi butta fuori quindi noi rimaniamo
dentro la a quello il culo quindi perché
mi sono sforzato tutto di merda non
perfetto italiano perso ciò prova quindi
si divide in due parti e che ne so io
quindi prendi la bomba dalla metrics
robot lo infilata nel culo di matt pixel
ok credo che anche questa sia giusta
perché perfetto ma non ho assolutamente
dubbi bene il primo è fatto ragazzi sono
entrato dentro me pixel
provo che figata roba che si dividono in
due livelli che faccio e alla pesce ma
sono inciampato sulla bomba maledizione
[Musica]
ma sei scemo a [ __ ]
ma no che ha buttato dentro la bomba
aveva riperso ce l'ho fatta però era
giusto
devo staccare i pin smin chiare e va
bene
no non era quello giusto va bene non
avevo dubbi guarda che non fosse quello
giusto tenti non mi presto in attimo
questa
grazie ad esso non vediamo più un cazzo
di esplodiamo uguale perfetto prendi il
tombino e mettilo dentro cosa perfetto
ho letto un tombino
ok ok ma che cazzo succede bene ragazzi
che sanno fare questa casa che sta
facendo è scemo era giusto
dovevo fare così ma come lei che sa se
con questa sono tre su tre ragazzi che
non ci potrei veramente credere
il buco non è non c'è non è la bomba la
prendo e la metto sono chantel sud
e vabbè allora sei scemo sono entrato
ovunque era giusto tre su tre bonus
round ragazzi non ho capito come ho
fatto ma va bene che bonus round e è
sempre questo che non si capisce va bene
prendo come pixel ometto oddio che caso
di cemento o picchiato
niente ho sbagliato la situazione nei
livelli bonus non si capisce che cosa
devo fare non si capisce bene va bene
sono riuscito a fare anche al round tra
i ragazzi ma anche all'ultimo che il
round 2 poi ho finito megapixel almeno
la storia principale poi non so se c'è
altra roba
credo di sì chapter quattro round 2 ex
explo delicious fammi vedere la vagonata
di livelli geniali che mi proponi zio e
io vi dichiaro ufficialmente marito è
wingardium leviosa perché c'ha le
mutande rosa al prete vabbè non importa
mi interessa pesa è saltata in aria
perché non sai fare benzina
quindi io ti prendo la miccia è giusto
mix
era giusto dovevo spegnere veramente la
micia lo so non sapevo perché l'avevo
già fatto in un altro livello non mi
ricordo quale però ok lei fa le
previsioni del meteo la riprendo la
riprendo a caso c'era una dinamite nella
videocamera non l'avrei mai detto che
sfiga questa mia moglie che tenta di
lanciarmi nonno la moglie sentita mila
bomba grazie ai lanciato al nonno ciak
che l'ha inghiottita e mia cagato in
faccia ho vinto
era giusto fa chi ha ragazzi ristorante
giapponese e riesco a fare anche questa
ragazzi sarebbe records su tre c'è una
poké ball picnic quale motivo non la
voglio usare sul lottatore di sumo la
uso su ma era una pokémon quella va beh
non importa
va bene marchetto c'è una pistolina la
posso usare contro nonno ciak che si e
sbarra ed è morto con una pistola
giocattolo ovviamente che si sta roba ma
cos'è una specie di di tenda per i
matrimoni senti moglie e mostra le tette
a lei ci aveva la via bastarda era una
menzogna al nostro matrimonio brutta
stronza [ __ ] niente lega non ho
capi a meno che non debba cambiare
quindi se io tolgo la nuvola diventa
sole niente sbagliati lancio questo
grazie mi ha catturato le va bene non è
servita un pene però va beh almeno mi ha
catturato una poké ball
ho sempre desiderato essere catturato da
una poca europa è una bomba
chiti rega wingardium leviosa è sparita
era una bacchetta magica sul serio e
quindi ho vinto è diventata una rana che
sia inghiottita la bomba perfetto su ca
questo è il karma brutta stronza perché
volevo uccidermi ce l'ho fatta da gama
mancano tre livelli ho finito in regalo
il sole zia perché tu sei tutta la mia
vita ci siamo abbronzati
qual è il senso ragazzi qual è il senso
della pistola non la devo usare su di
lui era una pistola ad acqua
io pisciato su una gamba bene o pisciato
sulla bomba che ho disinnescato perfetto
bene così posso fare solo una domanda
come ha fatto prima non lo sciacca
uccidersi con una pistola che spara
acqua la pioggia sulla bomba ce l'ho
fatta era una cosa ovvia come ho fatto
non arrivarci subito è rimasto l'ultimo
livello di me piste ragazzi questo
nessuno che non ho capito dall'asse
calcio lui non va bene se calcio da
poche voi non va bene non è che donne
italiane culo sì è giusto infila la mano
o magazzino valeva me pensavo di fare
una cosa più bella di questa prova vera
o catturato una dinamica e con la poké
ball geniale megapixel qua chi ha dei
sei fracassoli era casuale questo era
l'ultimo livello di mac pixar credo
c'è qualcosa no niente quindi ho finito
e basta con la gloria che mi accompagna
fantastico non ci posso credere che ce
l'ho fatta e stata la cosa più bella
della storia vi giuro le due cose che
rimangono da fare perché land raymond
sono tutti i veli che ho già fatto le
due cose che rimangono da fare ragazzi
sono bloccare gli extra che sarebbero
praticamente dei livelli che ti sblocchi
soltanto se provi tutte le opzioni
possibili di ogni livello e come ultima
cosa c'è anche freddi e si che sarebbe
il dlc di mac pixar perché si è bendato
lo sa ding sesta qua quanta roba hanno
fatto ma veramente quanta roba hanno
fatto non va bene non ci posso credere
ok mi sono sbagliato c'è tanta di quella
merda che non abbiamo mai finito c'è un
dlc che più grosso del gioco stesso
ragazzi fatemi sapere se volete di essi
io per ora concludo qui se volete i
livelli bonus di me pixel io gli farò
però fatemelo sapere nei commenti se non
mi fermo qua cosa serve se visto
l'argomento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook co il dottor
descrizione se residenti ci mettiamo
prossimo video bene ragazzi